dans le cadre de la donation Volare au
musée mondial en 1945
entre au musée 3 céramiques de Paul
Gauguin qui sont des céramiques
extrêmement importantes dans l'oeuvre en
fait du peintre on sait qu'il a il
connaît Gauguin peintre où tout le monde
a en tête certains peut-être de ces
paysages Tahitiens et Gauguin est un
peintre extrêmement important en fait
dans les années
1880 puisque c'est un peintre qui qui va
s'essayer à faire de la peinture à faire
de la céramique à faire de l'estampe à
finalement à faire ce que font
aujourd'hui encore beaucoup des artistes
qui sont un peu des des touches à tout
et dans les années 1080 il cessé à la
enfin il fait des essais de céramique en
fait il est il s'exprime avec la la
céramique et
donc c'est des céramiques que dont trois
exemplaires en fait sont arrivés ici au
musée Landers la pièce majeure la pièce
principale et ce masque de sauvage
qui est en céramique cuite avec des
couleurs qui ont été posées dessus que
Gauguin a gardé quasiment jusqu'à la fin
de sa vie à Tahiti
qu'il l'avait voulu diffusé en forme de
masque en bronze et on connaît au musée
d'Orsay une version en bronze de ce
masque là et il y a une autre version
qui se trouve en plâtre dans une
collection privée aux États-Unis mais la
seule et unique version en terre la plus
originale la plus intéressante ce masque
se trouve au musée landais c'est ce
masque bon qui est un peu inquiétant où
il a utilisé la la terre on l'appelle
masse au sauvage certains disent que
c'est peut-être aussi un peu un
autoportrait mais en tout cas c'est
quelque chose qui la garder avec lui
vraiment vraiment toute sa vie pour
pouvoir
comme quoi c'était quelque chose qui
auquel il était vraiment attaché
profondément
ce masque a une valeur inestimable
d'abord parce que il est unique il
n'existe qu'en un seul exemplaire il est
il a été fabriqué des mains de Paul
Gauguin et surtout les céramiques de
Gauguin en général sont extrêmement
rares et très collectionné en fait par
les musées mais aussi par les
collectionneurs privés il y a très très
peu d'exemplaires de céramique et
surtout ces céramique là c'est vraiment
quelque chose d'important aussi dans
l'histoire de l'art parce que c'est la
naissance de ce qu'on appelle un peu le
primitivisme c'est à dire cette
recherche par les artistes européens
d'autres sources d'inspiration que la
tradition européenne proprement dit qui
est hérité de du d'héritage Grégor
romain du claquisisme etc de la
Renaissance etc et Gauguin est l'un des
premiers justement et après ça va être
le cas de Pablo Picasso ça va être le
cas d'autres artistes à l'épuiser dans
autre chose dans d'autres choses pour
inventer finalement une nouvelle
esthétique inv enter une nouvelle forme
d'art et ce masque est une des étapes un
des une démarche justement dans ce
processus dans ce chemin justement vers
un renouvellement complet en fait de
l'esthétique en Europe à partie avec ce
qui commence dans les années 80 et qui
va triompher avec les Demoiselles
d'Avignon 1907 par Picasso